what is the relationship between these
two angles what are they called it's to
the next they're supplementary that add
to 180 degrees or they add two pi
radians
okay so how can i connect an angle and
it's supplement in terms of cosine okay
it's really easy
I think about it like it is if I have an
angle X what's the supplement of X I'm
in radians right it's PI takeaway X PI
takeaway X okay so I'm trying to
understand the supplement of X of what I
can say with this cosine okay but this
is just a pretty standard treat
expansion is it not it's a treaty
expansion when you expand trees mentions
because they're cause--'cause sign-sign
right so I'm gonna get cos PI cos x is
it plus or minus in the middle it's plus
because it causes backwards and then I
go sine sine happy yeah okay so here
what have I got well I know what cosplay
is and I know what sine PI is what's
closeby gonna graph its negative one
because these cause all the way is two
pi so he's PI and there's my value
negative one okay with that so cos x
turns into minus projects what's sine PI
notice one a little bit pick up it's
zero right because it goes BAM hit zero
okay so this is plus zero so now I have
a relationship between cosine of a value
of an angle and the cosine of its
supplement right so if I were to let X
equal PI oh nine in this case right I
would be able to say cos of Pi take away
PI or nine that's the SUP of it I'll
find a is equal to minus cos PI online
do you agree with that like that's just
a straight substitution here and this
connects the two men lose i mouthed up
there's cause a number line on the left
hand side and there's - correspond
just keep that in your back pocket now I
have a path to get from here to here but
now the next thing I need is how do I
connect this to an equation right
because it's like these two an equal to
it if I put this guy over the other side
it's equal to zero right how did serie
come into this I don't know anything
about Seabury yeah like what I'm trying
to say is write this which I don't know
yet this is what I'm trying to prove
right I'm writing this like so are you
okay with that like that I know how to
get to that that comes straight from
here because my a pile of nine is turned
into that - cosplay mine but how do I
know that this whole thing is equal to
zero
okay now anything into polynomial and
right what this is is the sum of roots
this is the sum of roots like that's in
fact what it means that's the way the
question is phrased right I've added up
all the roots and this is what I've got
now apparently according to the result
they're giving me the sum of all the
roots is equal to zero well where do I
get that from how can I Intuit that and
the answer is you come all the way back
to this equation that you give right now
this is not a quadratic it's not a
quadratic right but you can deal with it
in fact in this room get to this one we
do Colony was an extension one you can
deal with any polynomial and the sum and
parts of its roots in the same way that
you deal with them with a quadratic
right with a quadratic you get two roots
alpha plus beta what's the song no this
is really interesting right as we sort
of generalize this when we get to into
polynomials we do this for higher powers
this is actually not really sum and
product of roots okay they're actually
all sums it's just that the first line
is this sum one at a time and this is
the sum two at a time and if
I have a cubic I do the song three at a
time so this is what it would look like
if I generalize that right my next Greek
letter is scammer okay so if I had cube
roots I'd go in the Sun one at a time
there they are
1 1 1 to do them two at a time I can
pair them up in this many ways do you
see that that's all the ways I can
combine the three roots in pairs you see
that so that's the sum two at a time and
then what's this some three at a time
there's only one way to put all three of
them together Alpha Beta Gamma okay now
what's really interesting and we'll
prove this formally is that these
results are still exactly the same okay
and they generalize up they always have
a on the denominator I wondered if you
remember why from how we prove this
result okay and you're just taking each
of the coefficients you're climbing up
and you're alternating in signed of yes
sir mmm a is always the leading
coefficient okay so in this case because
my leading term is dead to the six my a
in this case will be one okay but if it
sneaky this pull what polynomial is
missing a whole bunch of terms is it not
that's missing a whole bunch of terms
there should be seven terms the six the
five before the three the two the one
and the constant that will be seven
terms but I've got a whole bunch missing
right I don't have any of the fires I
don't have any other fours
I don't have any of the twos or the ones
I've just got this guy this guy and this
guy right so being a is your leading
coefficient where's your next
coefficient it's that guy which is zero
so the summer fruits of this polynomial
is still - beyond a which is minus zero
on one okay you see how this is actually
something which we're gonna formally
meet later so it's kind of a bit of a
hack that you need to know it now that's
why you probably see this question board
of trial and in the test that's coming
up okay but nonetheless that idea is not
that crazy to get like we have the
reputable Osborne okay so here is what I
would say I would say that this guy here
right being the summer fruits I would
say two cars Superfund nine so this is
all what I was trying to prove this is
where I'm trying to go so now I'm
actually starting my working two of
those and two of those and two of these
that's equal to and I would state to
make the connection obvious I would say
it's - be on a and that's the summer
fruits okay so now I can evaluate this
thing right this is minus zero one as we
were saying which is zero okay since
it's zero I can divide both sides by two
there are trouble because you divide by
two still zero and then I'm gonna
substitute out my closet ain't piyo nine
because I don't actually what caused a
pie or nine I would call prior life so
that leaves me with this okay
I'm happy with that i expanded I've
divided by two and I swapped out this
guy okay from there is immaterial you're
pretty much up the result you're trying
to prove so I'm looking right down cuz
I'm at the bottom of my whiteboard okay
but that's the substance of how that
result comes about okay